[Música]
tem coisa que só sai da gente por
escrito
eu aprendi isso com meu avô joão ele
tinha uma oficina enquanto ele
consertava e pintava os carros ele
ficava silvy ando as músicas que tocavam
no rádio ficava brincando ali perto
a favorita do meu avô dizia contava a
história de um rapaz que queria aprender
a ler ea escrever
queria ser alfabetizado para poder
escrever um bilhete de amor e ele
explicar o motivo ele dizia na música se
não for por escrito eu não me anima
dizer muitos anos de estudo e de escrita
depois eu entendi que o meu avô me deu a
melhor herança que ele podia me dar que
é um conhecimento porque a palavra
escrita carrega em si que nós somos
profundamente quem nós somos sem
máscaras sociais e é por isso que ela
auxilia em processo de autoconhecimento
na redução dos níveis de estresse na
colagem dos corações partidos e na
comunicação interna e externa para que
isso aconteça precisa criar o hábito da
escrita
às vezes a gente acha que precisa
escrever coisas grandiosas e que precisa
e que a escrita vem como um dom e ela é
um exercício e assim como o exercício
ela qualquer outro exercício precisa de
constância precisa de star wars e
precisa de atenção o que tu vai escrever
todos os dias isso pode começar a
escolher eu tenho o aluno começou a
escrever e mails pra ele mesmo e raiva
não sei escrever todo dia eu não sei nem
por onde começa e começou a escrever
pequenos e mail assim com dois
parágrafos contando sobre o dia e até
que em determinado momento ele começou a
responder
e hoje em dia tem uma levemente doida
mas maravilhosa correspondência com ele
mesmo e ele também sabe quem é
e com que ele sonha uma outra aluna
linha em aula descobriu que ela tinha
muita dificuldade de utilizar palavras
gentis com ela ela utilizava palavras
gentis com as outras pessoas ela era
muito amorosa com as pessoas e quando
ela se referia se ano não tinha palavras
gentis
então ela quer um projeto em que ela
escreveu cartas de alto valor
durante mais ou menos um ano todos os
dias ela se esforçava para encontrar
palavras gentis pra ela eu
particularmente na minha escrita diária
escrevo sempre diálogos imaginários
entre as pessoas no metrô no ônibus eu
entre maggi nos vidas maravilhosas
bruxelas ou às vezes um pouco práticas e
às vezes finge que as pessoas se
conhecem entre os diálogos e também
escrevo cartas de amor para todos os
assuntos eu tenho um acervo de carta de
amor
se alguém tiver precisam de alguma me
pede que empresto é tranqüilo
efe a escrita diária faz com que a gente
reconheça a nossa voz da escrita
a nossa voz da escrita é quem nós somos
100 assim as nossas referências porque
quando a gente começa em qualquer
processo criativo
a gente tem referências muito grande ea
gente começa a se comparar com elas em
muitos momentos a gente tenta escrever
como elas como as nossas referências e
isso também pode ser bastante assustador
é engraçado que sempre que eu pergunto
pra alguém é quanto à referência quem é
a pessoa que adora ele é as pessoas
sempre se se comparam com onde a pessoa
está agora não é com a mão não se
comparar com a trajetória não tá ali no
começo é que a pessoa é hoje que gosta
dele outro gosta de assistir se a pessoa
tem uma trajetória enorme talvez isso
esteja projetor e eu preciso respeitar
isso
a nossa voz da escrita é o nosso jeito
de dizer que amanheceu chovendo ou que
quando uma pessoa sorri a primavera se
inicia independente do mês em que a
gente esteja o nosso jeito
de contar alguma coisa o nosso que é o
único pessoal e intransferível e a gente
encontra ele através do exercício é como
desenhar todo mundo desenha em
determinado momento algumas pessoas
continuam desenhando e é o esforço
contínuo é a atenção plena que faz com
que continue tem um poema de uma poeta
que eu adoro um trechinho de um poema
que ela fala se você me ama porque você
não se concentra e faz todo sentido com
a escrita diária a partir do momento em
que a gente tem a nossa a gente começa
com a escrita diária
a gente começa a gente pode começar a
externar é publicar os nossos textos
colocar os nossos que isso seja na nossa
rede social seja num grande jornal uma
revista no livro quiser
é a partir da nota do encontro da nossa
voz da escrita que a gente espera as
nossas palavras sempre lembrando de uma
coisa fundamental
a partir do momento em que coloca os
seus textos
eu brinco a partir do momento que o bota
o bloco na rua a partir do momento em
que coloca os teus textos para que as
outras pessoas possam ler é preciso
lembrar que as suas palavras estão a
serviço das pessoas à tua palavra está
ali para ofertar conhecimento para mim
era de seu universo para melhor ofertar
informação melhorar a capacidade crítica
de alguém para fazer uma pessoa resgatar
um resgate de humanidade para a pessoa
fazer uma reflexão sobre o amor em
tempos de ódio precisa oferecer a tua
palavra para abrir portas e de
preferência construir pontes jamais
muros
se uma pessoa termina de ler o texto e
ela se ela não se sente informada ou
viva ou feliz porque ela tem uma
informação que ela não tinha antes
precisa só refazer o texto a gente
escreve pra acender estrelas dentro das
pessoas para que as idéias das pessoas
sejam iluminadas
para que as pessoas tenham novas dúvidas
que eram saber mais se desconhece um
pouquinho para que as pessoas possam
reconhecer a beleza a liberdade ea
esperança e é por isso que eu vim aqui
hoje para fazer um convite bem simples
pra vocês é que vocês deslocam o coração
de vez em quando não precisa ser o tempo
todo no peito até a pontinha dos dedos
vem comigo
[Aplausos]